تباعا الى الى انقره وايضا المواقف
الرسميه وما الذي
يتم تداوله في العاصمه التركيه انقره بشان
هذا الزلزال
والنتائجه فرح
اثناء في الغرفه المجاوره لي هنا في اداره
الطوارئ يعقد المدير العام لتقليل مخاطر
الزلازل مؤتمرا صحفيا جديدا يحدث فيه هذه
الارقام تحدث عن 14 قتيل حتى الان زياده
في عدد الجرحى كذلك يزيد عدد المباني
المهدمه يصل الى اكثر من 2,8 ويؤكد وقوع
105 هزات ارتداديه منذ الصباح هذا يعني
زياده كبيره في الارقام خلال وقت قياسي
الرئيس التركي قبل ساعه تقريبا اعلن عن
900 قتيل والان تعلن اداره الكوارث عن
ارتفاع هذا العدد الى 14
والمباني المهدمه تقترب من ثلاثه الاف
مبنى والهزات الارتداديه تزداد وتصل الى
105 هزه ارت منها ما زاد عن سته درجات على
مقياس ريستور اهمها تطرق اليه خلال
المؤتمر المستمر في هذه الاثناء الى مساله
تكذيب الاخبار او نفي الاخبار التي يتم
تداولها عن احتمال وقوع موجات تسونامي او
زلزال في البحر الابيض المتوسط صدرت
العديد من الانباء التي تم تبادلها على
بعض المواقع او وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
والتي تحذر من امكانيه وقوع موجات تسونامي
وذلك بعد وقوع زلزال جديد ثاني بعد
الزلزال الذي وقع فجر اليوم الى جانب
الهزات الارتداديه الشديده يدعو المواطنين
هنا الى الهدوء الى الحيطه والحذر بطبيعه
الحال شده هذا الزلزال الذي وقع فجر اليوم
بعد ان اعلن عبر المواقع الرسميه التركيه
بانها كانت 7.4 اكدت اداره الكوارث بانها
وصلت الى 7.7 درجه على مقياس ريختر ما
يجعله واحدا من اكبر الزلازل التي تشهدها
تركيا وهو ما يزيد التوقعات بان ترتفع هذه
الارقام
تباعا لا سيما مع استمرار عمليات
الانقاذ تقول اداره الكوارث انه لم يحدث
زلزال كهذا في تركيا منذ
التسعينيات وهو ما وصفه الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان بانه واحده من اكبر الكوارث
التي تمر على تركيا عمق هذا الزلزال وصل
الى سبعه كيلومترات واستمر لفتره تعتبر
طويله زمنيا اذا ما تمت مقارنته بهزاد
ثانيه وهو ما يبرر
هذا او هذه الارقام الكبيره
المتعلقه بالمباني المنهاره او بسقوط عدد
كبير من القتلى
وبالجرحى الان في يتابع 23
واليا يتابعون الاوضاع عن كثب فرق الانقاذ
المكونه من تسعه الاف شخص عدد مرجح لزياد
مع وصول طواقم اخرى الى المناطق المتضرره
بعض الطواقم تحاول الوصول عبر الممرات
التي امنتها وزاره الدفاع التركيه
غالبيتها ممرات جويه وذلك بسبب ان سوء
الاحوال الجويه وتساقط الثلوج الجليد الذي
اغلق الطرقات البريه المؤديه الى تلك
المناطق يجعل الامور غير سهله وغير سلسه
بطبيعه الحال الان هناك تحذيرات من مساله
الهزات الارتداديه دعوات للمواطنين بعدم
دخول المباني المتضرره في منطقه غازي
عنتاب تحديدا هنالك مباني قديمه تضررت
للغايه يوجد فيها تصدعات وتشققات وتدعو
اداره الكوارث المواطنين الى دخول هذه
المباني
والذهاب الى اماكن اخرى حتى وان كان الطقس
قارصا هذه المنطقه التي تمتد على صدع
زلزالين يسمى بصدع شرق
الاناضول يصفه الان الخبراء بانه اصبح
نشطا نشط منذ عام 2020 حيث وقع زلزال في
منطقه تركيه ثانيه ادت الى تحرك
الانزلاقات الارضيه وادت الى نشاطه ويقول
هؤلاء الخبراء بانهم توقعوا في الحقيقه
هذا الامر لا سيما ان تركيا
تتواجد في منطقه زلزاليه واختبرت اكثر من
مره زلازل مدمره في الحقيقه معنى